Je suis Molly Bloom, c'est une histoire vraie. J'ai
décidé de prendre une année sabbatique avant la
fac de droit, alors j'ai trouvé un emploi d'
assistante de bureau chez Molly. Mon jeu de poker hebdomadaire
est passé au déjeuner Cobra.
[ __ ] ne dis à personne la semaine prochaine
c'est pour toi merci beaucoup
je vais arrêter de te payer avec mon
assistant bien je ne vire pas je vais juste
arrêter de te payer tu es payé une fois
par semaine à partir du jeu  ne semble pas
juste, vous allez arrêter de me payer parce que
je gagne trop d'argent en faisant mon
deuxième travail et si je dis non, je perdrai les
deux emplois parce que cela ne semble pas juste,
vous n'avez pas de pouvoir de négociation ici  Je
n'allais pas attendre avant de mettre un plan en
place J'organiserai un jeu dans cette
suite tous les mardis soirs il y a un buy-in de
250 000 qui va faire du bruit
jouons J'étais dans une pièce avec des
réalisateurs de stars de cinéma et des Titans d'affaires
dans l'ensemble, j'étais le plus grand
coureur de jeux au monde,
vous avez 2,8 milliards dans la rue en ce
moment, vous êtes  va faire exploser,
comprenez-vous que vous êtes accusé d'
exploiter une entreprise de jeu illégale,
vous ne prenez pas de pourcentage du pot,
non, je vais le garder comme ça parce que vous
n'enfreignez pas la loi lorsque vous enfreignez
la
loi.  Je ne suis pas vraiment en mesure de savoir avec certitude
que les lois ne sont pas écrites. Avez-vous
vu les autres noms dans votre acte d'accusation
venir sur mati juste au plus profond de la
foule russe où êtes-vous pourquoi vous dans
ce seul où sont les gens vous  sont
protégés en ne racontant pas toute l'histoire